le parc régional du perche a pour
caractéristique une diversité de
paysages notre parcours commence ici
derrière le village des eti yeux
premières impressions
les bruits des activités humaines
s'évanouissent au profit des bruits
naturels
vous n'entendrez que le bruit de vos pas
ceux de votre cheval ou le bruit de
votre vélo
jean-pierre notre guide nous rejoint
dans cette partie du perche intimiste
fait de chemins creux et de blocage une
forme agricoles traditionnelles la
particularité des et qui lui est son
intérêt c'est finalement le bocage qui
est une des constituants essentiels du
paysage percheron et bien le bocage est
encore très bien formés et on s'en
aperçoit lorsque l'on regarde autour de
nous il y a des assez nombreux encore un
maillage bocager très important ses
parents des prairies mais quelques
chambres le perche tient son nom de
silva père ti-cats vertica perche unité
de mesure agraire utilisé par les
romains et silva forêt on atteint perche
primitivement et être une région comme
beaucoup de régions de france recouvert
par une forêt relativement profonde et 7
aux dépens de cette forêt que l'homme a
petit à petit construit ce paysage de
bocage est donc une fois qu'il a décidé
de se sédentariser s'est fait de la
place pour installer ses chants et ses
prêts et cette place il se l'est faite
au détriment de la fois ce qui est
intéressant le parc du perche c'est que
nous avons une sorte de mosaïque de
milieux différents le bocage certes mais
également des plateaux cultiver de
grands arcs forestier et puis parfois
même au sommet des collines des forêts
reddy's résiduelles donc des morceaux de
forêts qui sont restés de l'ancien silva
parti cas de l'ancienne forêt qui
couvraient tout le perche
jusqu'à ce que l'homme ne se
sédentarisent direction la colline de
rougemont à 15 km un point culminant
ici le bocage tend à disparaître
l'agriculture influencé par la beauce
créé de grandes parcelles pour le parc
dont la mission est la gestion du
patrimoine
il s'agit de préserver valoriser et
développer l'intérêt du territoire
notamment pour des objectifs
touristiques et pour que le tourisme
fonctionne encore faut-il que les
spécificités agréable du parc du perche
soit conservé
et donc le parc se lance dans une sorte
de reconquête du bocage c'est à dire que
le parc participe à la replantation de
haies sur parti participe financièrement
à la replantation de haies ronde aidant
les agriculteurs ou les particuliers qui
veulent se lancer dans la replantation
de haies et donc l'idée c'est de faire
en sorte que le paysage qui est la
ressource agréable et principal du
perche en tout cas d'un point de vue
touristique a bien que cette
particularité perdure finalement on
comprend que un parc naturel régional et
limane est une émanation locale se dire
que c'est la population qui porte en
quelque sorte
ce projet est donc encore faut-il que
cette population sache quels sont les
richesses qui sont propres à son
territoire témoin de l'histoire et des
savoir faire d'autrefois le patrimoine
bâti du cinquième au 20e siècle est une
des principales richesses du perche
afin d'aider à sa préservation et sa
prise en compte dans les projets
d'aménagement
le parc conduit des inventaires qui
permettent aux habitants et aux élus de
découvrir éléments architecturaux et
matériaux locaux tirées du sol si nous
partions du haut d'une colline pour nous
diriger vers le centre de la terre nous
passerions d'abord par l'argile l'argile
à silex l'argile qui a eu dix étaient
utilisés pour faire les briques et pour
faire les ardoises le silex pour faire
le tout venant des murs ensuite nous
trouverions une couche de sable sous
cette couche d'argile à silex le sable
qui a utilisé pour faire les enduits qui
donnent tout leur chaleur au bâti
percheron ensuite si nous continuons
notre voyage vers le centre de la terre
et bien nous trouverions des masses de
calcaire dans lesquelles ont été prises
les pierres que vous voyez ici
jean-pierre nous propose une halte au
bord de la cloche une petite rivière qui
l'air de rien participent à un réseau
hydrographique dense pour notre guide
l'eau est le premier vecteur de
l'installation des hommes dans le perche
l'eau a une importance majeure dans le
perche comme dans d'autres régions sans
doute d'un point de vue paysager d'une
part puisque c'est à cause de l'érosion
fluviale à cause de l'érosion de l'eau
que les collines se sont petit à petit
forme et au fil des films des
millénaires une importance historique
parce que sur ces rivières des moulins
ont été installés alors évidemment des
moulins pour moudre le blé mais
également des moulins qui avait vocation
à
apporter l'énergie nécessaire au
fonctionnement des verreries et des
fonderies et puis pour finir bien que
l'on pourrait rester longtemps sur ce
sujet les rivières ont aussi un rôle
écologique majeure puisqu'elle abrite un
cortège faunistique et floristique très
important que le parquet cei avec
l'ensemble de la population de préserver
notre parcours s'achève avec une petite
frustration devant l'immensité de ce
territoire à découvrir et une envie y
revenir